réputation du clément district shop
n'est plus à faire on y prépare dit dont
les meilleurs sans doute de la région
joe biden ne dira pas le contraire
c'est un habitué on le voit au moins
deux fois par année dit marianne rachkov
qui elle travaille ici depuis 11 ans il
est toujours très gentils dit elle comme
ceux qui l'entourent elle se réjouit de
sa candidature car il faut dit-elle se
débarrasser d'un autre homme marianne
n'a pas voté lors de la dernière
élection
elle regrette encore sénateur du
delaware pendant 36 ans
joe biden a laissé sa marque washington
une ville où les afro américains
représentent 60% de la population
la gare ferroviaire portent son nom la
piscine où il a travaillé dans sa
jeunesse aussi john davis habite juste
en face
il se définit comme un républicain mais
ils considèrent l'élection de donald
trump comme une grave erreur
il votera joe biden cette fois ci car
selon lui la situation l'exigé nous
sommes au milieu d'une pandémie avec une
crise économique et du désordre civil
gentilles on a besoin de quelqu'un qui
nous redonne un peu de normalité mais
l'élection est loin d'être joué car ce
n'est pas un mais bien deux obstacles
qui se dressent sur le chemin de joe
biden faire la maison blanche
dans notre chambre bien sûr mais aussi
l'abstention c'est queen jones par
exemple a déjà décidé de ne pas voter
très impliqué en politique il se dit
progressiste il soutenait que nissan 2
il ne se reconnaît pas dans le parti
démocrate actuelle les démocrates
tiennent pour acquis le vote des afro
américains dit il thomas hayden ne fait
qu'appliquer la recette et n'apporte
rien de neuf
comme bien des jeunes de sa génération
c'est quan va donc boudé les urnes non
par paresse mais par conviction
et si jean françois bélanger
radio-canada wellington